police just wrapped up a news conference
on two police shootings both happening
this past Friday one was near Charleston
and lamb the other was across town near
Summerlin Hospital Medical Center near
Summerlin Parkway no officer was injured
Joshua peguero Joins us live from Metro
Police Headquarters with an update on
both of these incidents Joshua
now both shootings happened within hours
of each other they marked the 13th and
14th metro police shootings of 2022
measure police today identified both
people that were shot and killed in that
first shooting on Charleston and lamb it
was 60-year-old William Allen conkle Jr
police say conkle was involved in a road
rage incident at 11 Friday morning on
Nellis and Bonanza he apparently stole a
gun from someone on a motorcycle then
pulled out a gun at another driver
police located conkle but he took off
leading them on a chase that ended on
Colusa circle Concord allegedly fired
one round that officers three officers
then returned fire and combined 41
rounds
conquer was able to put his vehicle in
gear and then drove towards the officers
officers once again fired their weapons
at conkle who then crashed into a brick
wall in front of the house
and in the other shooting in Summerlin
Metro identified the person as 58 year
old Paul horn police say horn had
confronted a driver with his gun after
accusing them of speeding on his streets
police were called to the neighborhood
and officers asked horn to come out of
the house he did but with a gun pointed
to his head he fired his gun as this at
the same time as an officer fired one
round according to police a coroner
ruled Horn's death as a self-inflicted
gunshot wound reporting live on Metro
Police Headquarters near MLK and Alta
Joshua progero eight news now thank you
with Joshua Metro Police say body cams
did not capture the moments when Paul
horn shot himself or when the officer
fired his weapon but horn had
surveillance cameras around his house
that were told showed him leaving his
home with a gun to his head and then
pulling the trigger